yo so you did a TED Talk that was like
the biggest Ted Talk of the year yeah
was that very uh were you were you
nervous preparing for that because
that's a big deal to do it yeah bro I
was off that's one of them shroom nights
bro like when I had that bad I was like
[__] I got this Ted talk to do next week
that wasn't the man it was a uh uh
[__] it was a bunch of [__] Bro a
bunch of [__] it was a lot of [__] but
um going back to the TED Talk
hmm
I am
that I was something I wanted to do
because I'm like yo it's just some cool
[__] and then when they actually reached
out like yeah we want coordinator to do
a techno oh [__] I didn't know right so
what was the question again
talk about preparing for that like you
know that's a big speech to write a lot
of I wrote a speech and then I'll I sent
it over to Ted Talk and they had like
certain notes about it and I'm like bro
like
I don't like what the they sent me like
you know edit notes like this is cool
but this ain't and so I kind of started
panicking because I'm like I just want
to write what I want to write and so I
just end up just doing that I just
ignored their notes and just deal with
it was the biggest one you know the
biggest one you're gonna do another one
no not no time someone I gotta I gotta I
think I before I do another one I gotta
do some more [__] like some more
legendary stuff you know